dans le sud de la touraine la cité
royale de loches son château ses
chambres d'hôtes et ses hôtels sont
endormis depuis un an pour les réveiller
un jeu concours a été mis en place des
chèques cadeaux pour attirer les
touristes
c'est un chèque sortie de kovy le chèque
cadeau se présente par cinq coupons de
10 euros donc c'est un moyen en fait qui
va permettre en fait aux gagnants de
dépenser en fait ces coupons sur
différents sites avec différents
prestataires un petit peu dans un
restaurant un qui peut sur la location
de vélos
concrètement vous réserver trois nuits
dans la région et vous pouvez tenter
votre chance sur ce site internet
quand les trois images sa ligne c'est le
jackpot
à quelques kilomètres de là patricia et
henri arnould participent à cette
opération
ils ouvrent les portes de leur demeure
avec piscine jardin et quatre chambres
d'hôtes
ils accepteront ces chèques cadeaux pour
paiement pour eux c'est un plus qui rend
optimiste j'espère je suis même certaine
que ça va inciter les gens réservé
peut-être une nuit supplémentaire dès
que vous faites un cadeau à quelqu'un
les gens sont toujours ravis même si
c'est 10 euros qui vous laisse dans le
projet et qu'ils vont dépenser leur est
d'ailleurs ça n'a pas d'importance c'est
le geste qui compte
et je pense que voilà le jeu en vaut la
chandelle de toute façon pour les hôtels
de la région même espoir avec une vue
imprenable sur l'indre pour le moment la
salle de restaurant restent vides alors
pour le propriétaire le chèque cadeau
peut donner un petit coup de pouce bien
utile c'est une bonne opportunité et
pour l'hôtel et pour le client
seul effet une réduction donc j'avais
tout ce qui peut attirer nos clients
d'oran l'hôtellerie c'est ce serait ces
du bien venu et pour ouvrir encore plus
grand la porte à une nouvelle clientèle
la cité médiévale propose une immersion
dans le donjon un jeu d'évasion qu'on
appelle aussi escape game la règle de
cette activité est simple passer une
petite demi heure dans un endroit un peu
un peu secret du château avec des
énigmes pour pouvoir sortir en moins de
30 minutes d'un des espaces
dissimulée de ce lieu c'est aussi une
manière un peu innovante de faire
revenir le public et dans cette petite
ville de 7000 habitants des invités
exceptionnels
ses statuts du trésor de naples elle
s'installe pour quatre mois
parmi ces joyaux le mystère de san
gennaro dont le sang se liquéfie ray
trois fois par an des oeuvres si
précieuses qu'elles n'ont voyager que
deux fois en sept siècles
de quoi attirer le public on commence à
surtout le confinement c'est l'été je
pense que pour beaucoup de français ça
sera intéressant de se promener par ces
lieux historiques du sud touraine
redoublent d'efforts pour relancer le
tourisme après une longue période de
sommeil